[Música]
es su primer abrazo en 6 años el comité
internacional de la cruz roja logró
localizar al tío de jason y esther en
esta ciudad a cientos de kilómetros de
donde habían encontrado refugio después
de que milicias asaltaron su aldea y
mataron a sus padres hasta en parte de
los 83 niños que fueron reunidos con sus
familias esta semana en república
democrática del congo ahora estoy feliz
de volver a ver a los hijos de mi
hermano
hemos estado separados durante mucho
tiempo debido a los constantes combates
entre las milicias y el ejército
estoy muy contento de estar en casa con
mi propia familia
fue duro perder a mis padres y ahora soy
muy feliz con mi tío
quiero ir a la escuela a estudiar ser un
niño normal el número de niños separados
de sus familias sigue aumentando
especialmente en la provincia del club
del norte donde los rebeldes del m 23
lanzaron una nueva ofensiva en los
últimos meses este grupo armado acusa al
gobierno congoleño de marginar a su
minoría étnica y volvió a tomar armas a
finales de 2021 el ccr alerta sobre las
múltiples consecuencias para la
población la operación que estamos
dirigiendo ahora mismo se enfoca en los
niños separados de sus familias pero
como otra consecuencia del conflicto
también está la pérdida de medios de
subsistencia para estas familias
el sistema que establecieron el ccr y la
cruz roja local permitió reunificar a
casi 200 niños con sus familias en los
últimos seis meses y a más de 2500 niños
entre 2017 y 2021 pero la violencia está
lejos de su fin y la atención sigue
creciendo ahora una república
democrática del congo acusa a ronda de
respaldar al n23 para provocar
inestabilidad y poder explotar las ricas
minerales de la región